a healthy diet consists of getting about
half your food in the form of fruits and
vegetables about one third of your food
from whole grains protein plants your
legumes your beans your chickpeas your
lentils your black beans and all that
good stuff bacon and processed meat zero
bacon processed meats are probably
responsible for 640 000 deaths every
year on Earth and but in the body of the
report they said look the safest amount
of red meat to consume is probably zero
but it's difficult to demonstrate harm
at low levels of consumption so we've
allowed this within the within the
within the healthy place when it came to
eggs they reckoned about a half an egg
per day when it came to Fish and Chicken
one to two ounces per day but it was
clear reading the report that if you are
lucky enough and privileged enough to
live in a situation where you have
access to all of these foods and not
everybody does that's for sure then
choosing plants first is definitely the
way forward